ah hello it is Friday here on its price
I did a medium poor job of shooting
stuff this week so here is some stuff
that I shot would you like to say
something
everyone ready
we're living for the next destination
for hey USA I'm getting myself together
I'm a little late as always ha mm-hmm
anyway I just shot a video for its grace
just went to shake us my hotel set up
for all you tech junkies out there that
really want to know hi
here's my tripod this is the cover to a
tissue box
it's my ice container this is a tray
they give you for the ice because it's a
[ __ ] classy establishment there's
some fruit that I took with the best of
intentions of not actually eating but by
choosing them feel like I'm a better
person because I touched them I'm not
touching my crotch I'm touching the
chair bad
very very forward-thinking that's fake
I'm a [ __ ]
yeah no but the eyelashes look like
hedgehogs oh no eyelashes and the mother
diverse is it that day come on guy from
that mug shot
hello you're welcome to would probably
clean this bathroom tour hey go man
hey girl hey hey oh hey hey girl hey
sincerely I thought for a second there
was actual girl and that's all this is
clean oh look at I'm in New Orleans
right now for hey USA by the way oh that
rhymed
want to see my great view oh I miss New
York reminds me of a beautiful beautiful
view in New York
we're not going to care